das ulmer münster eindrucksvoll und
einzigartig das hier ist der höchste
kirchturm der welt warum ist da
eigentlich so hoch wie fühlt es sich an
um den turm herum zu fliegen warum wird
er ständig gebaut und wie schnell
deutlich nach oben
der höchste kirchturm der welt wird
einige fragen aus für die antworten
steige ich zunächst nach ganz oben 768
stufen zu fuß einen aufzug gibt es nicht
in 143 metern höhe dem himmel also schon
ziemlich nahe wartet pfarrer peter
schaal ahlers auf mich
manche sagen das ist wie ein fingerzeig
dass da oben nochmal im himmel eine
andere dimension ist aber das hörten
sich mir sehr fromme ich fast zu frommen
an um wahr zu sein
161 meter 53 mit der kirchturm
weltrekord und das in ulm
die stadt hat gerade mal 125.000
einwohner
sie liegt im süden deutschlands direkt
an der donau einst war wohl meine
mächtige und wohlhabende stadt
überraschend ein hochwertiger stoff war
weltweit gefragt das münster zeugt noch
heute vom einstigen reichtum nicht nur
der turm des gigantisch sondern auch der
gotischen kirchenraum
ich bin einer von rund einer million
besuchern jährlich und bestaune die
sakralen kunst schätze es ist das größte
evangelische gotteshaus deutschlands das
aller wesentlichste ist dass es eine
bürger kirche ist und das heißt also
nicht ein kirche nicht einen bischof hat
den idee gehabt diese kirche zu bauen
sondern die bürger selber und man sagt
das selbstbewusstsein der ulmer so hoch
wie der kirchturm das gründungs relief
zeigt die grundsteinlegung im jahr 1377
schon sehr früh hatten die ulmer
division den höchsten kirchturm der welt
zu errichten
doch 1543 gegen das geld aus der bau
wurde gestoppt erst 300 jahre später
wurde die kirche in ihrer jetzigen form
fertiggestellt
fertiggestellt ist für michael hilbert
allerdings ein fremdwort
als münster baumeister ist er dafür
zuständig die bausubstanz der kirche zu
erhalten
in der münsterbauhütte sind 24
mitarbeiter damit beschäftigt jeden
einzelnen stein zu prüfen zu
restaurieren oder auszutauschen
für die steinmetze eine filigrane arbeit
[Musik]
nationales denkmal eben in diesen
zustand zu restaurieren
dann muss man auch bis in den letzten
winkel
diese detailverliebtheit an den tag
legen
das ulmer münster aus der
vogelperspektive zu erleben eigentlich
unmöglich doch mit dem ganzkörper
flugsimulator berkeley und einer vr
brille wird es möglich ich fliege
virtuell durch ulm im jahre 1890 und
komme dem münster nach
sehr sogar
wahnsinn wahnsinn wirklich ich komme
jetzt zeigen sich in einem völlig
anderen raum wieder also dass ich jetzt
wieder hier bin das man sie erst noch
nicht lange mögen
zurück im realen ulmer münster viele
besucher kommen ja ausschließlich um den
kirchturm zu besteigen und manche
machten sogar einen sport daraus beim
jährlichen ulmer münsterturm lauf rennen
sie um die wette
560 stufen bis auf 102 meter
der gewinner des vergangenen jahres hat
zwei minuten 36 gebraucht da kann ich
leider nicht mithalten
mich hat es geschafft in fünf minuten
doch hochlaufen ob schnell oder langsam
lohnt sich allemal
es gibt ein wesentlich höher gelegene
aussichtspunkte auf der welt aber das
ulmer münster hoch zu laufen da aller
geschichte drum herum das ist schon mal
sehr sehr besonderes auch wenn er
vielleicht nicht für immer der höchste
kirchturm der welt bleiben wird 1 wird
das ulmer münster immer seien
herausragend
[Musik]